m
le pôle emploi de saint pierre et la
mairie de la ville ont organisé ce mardi
24 mai le ca qui bouge pour l'emploi une
manifestation répartis sur 4 sites afin
de proposer au public des informations
pratiques pour les aider dans leur
insertion professionnelle
vous souhaitez avec la mairie mobiliser
les différents acteurs de l'insertion de
l'orientation de la formation pour
apporter un premier niveau de réponse
aux problématiques constater et de
s'intégrer
le cheminement cheminement donc plus 42
partenaires ont été mobilisés autour de
cette formation qui se déroule dans la
ville avec une volonté de mettre en
mouvement autour de l'emploi pour les
publics demandeurs d'emploi de faire
bouger pour un emploi et de trouver dans
quatre pôles identifier
donc des réponses aux questions donc ce
côté les demandes d'emploi afin de
concrétiser un parcours
assertion est de retour encore parmi les
quarante partenaires participants le
conseil départemental était présent avec
l'équipe du pôle insertion et la mission
sociale rsa sur le site qui accompagne
dans les locaux du pôle emploi
l'assertion l'insertion missions
sociales rsa est vif du conseil demande
à tout maintenant en plein
consécutivement le pôle insertion et la
mission sociale très simple
mais en fait déjà c'est une action
territoriale pour le département prend
toute sa place
on prend donc sur le ca qui bouge dans
montré que le département bouge qui est
vraiment dans l'action avec les
partenaires et le but du jeu c'est de
présenter donc le département via ces
deux services que sont le pôle insertion
et la mission sociale de la nation
c'est vraiment dispensé de l'information
est comment dire montrer aux gens tout
ce que le département peut faire et
mettre en oeuvre dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement des personnes sont
bénéficiaires
une manifestation qui a su réunir tous
les interlocuteurs dans un même secteur
un véritable gain de temps pour le
public
alors en fait on est présent aujourd'hui
parce que je suis actuellement dans
masson ms donc technicien médiation et
services et le but de la journée c'est
bas deux points des informations avec
les différentes personnes présentes pour
que l'on puisse nous par la suite aider
les personnes dans le besoin qui
l'impliquent nous rencontrer en fait on
n'a pas forcément le temps d'aller voir
toutes ces personnes individuellement
sans savoir exactement ce qu'elles font
donc là de pouvoir passer d'avoir les
claques est de discuter un petit peu
avec les gens à droite à gauche ça nous
permet d'avoir plus d'informations
tout au long de la journée les quatre
sites ont accueilli beaucoup de monde
une manifestation réussie tout comme
celle organisée le 2 mai dernier seniors
où en êtes-vous avait également remporté
un franc succès